I'm going to start with congratulations
for not crashing the Ferrari oh thank
you you know what I mean I think you
guys have done it again and um I wish
that the third movie was coming out next
week
um see in a year listen I got about a
thousand questions let's just let's be
serious so you guys know that I'm a fan
of when you're directing yes and since
I'm the two of you are sitting here I
have to ask what is the next project you
are directing
um we I know we
trying not to commit ourselves to
anything we're very excited about a
bunch of our future projects we're
particularly excited about uh project
Hail Mary
um which uh you know once we get through
the various strikes
[Music]
um and and get all that buttoned up
um we're hoping to get to work on it so
that is probably your next project that
you I'm looking at Chris because he's
more responsible than I am
um yeah you know obviously uh there's a
lot uh to figure out but uh it's looking
that way uh my one other thing before
getting into the movie uh you there's
been talk of a live-action spider Noir
series yes and so I'm just curious is
that actually something that's really
moving forward is it yes it is it is or
at least it was until the writer strike
and everything shut down but once the
once uh
that gets resolved uh we'll get uh back
into it but it's it's coming along
nicely uh is there any chance Nick Cage
will be involved there is any chance
so this the first film was called into
the spider-verse the sequel is across
the spider verse and um the third one is
beyond the spider verse yes I have
realized that these are very literal
titles and um now that I've seen the
second movie so does beyond the spider
verse have is there any chance that any
of these characters will be seen in live
action because it's beyond the spider
verse
um I will say that uh the what's special
about this film is that is the fact that
uh we can represent worlds in in unique
uh Styles and every world uh looks like
a different artist's hand and the
animation style and the and everything
about it is unique and bespoke for each
world that it goes into and so that you
know that could be anything but I would
it would be
it would it would if the movie itself
was in live action then you wouldn't be
able to take advantage of all of that
that said all things are possible in the
Multiverse well I mean like because
there's I don't want to get specific but
there are moments in this movie that
exist in very a small pocket if you will
right so that's why I was wondering if
Beyond could mean a small pocket of live
action it means a lot of things but it
also means you know we see a sort of map
representation of the known
uh Spider verse uh but there are things
that kind of exist outside of that web
of life and Destiny if you will so one
of the things obviously the first film
is a huge hit people love it people are
going to love this movie and I know that
the studio loves the fact that these
movies are incredible and that I would
imagine after the third one basically
what I'm asking is do you think that
more spin-offs and other offshoots or
other movies will continue or do you
envision this as a just a three sort of
three chapter installment well one
chapter at a time
uh I think it's obvious that um there's
infinite possibilities
um the the only thing that's finite is
the amount of um energy that we all have
right these things are very exhausting
hugely ambitious uh and take a lot of
people working really hard and
dedicating themselves to doing something
new and special and so after each one
we're also exhausted uh you know and
knowing that we have another one uh you
know that we have to finish and is is
daunting uh in its own way because we
want to make sure that that's excellent
uh as those that came before it and and
surprising and new and and unlike
anything you've ever seen before and so
you know I thinking about Beyond doing
this Trilogy is uh is quite terrifying
that's a good title though beyond beyond
indeed oh so listen uh I'm so curious
about the writing process putting these
how did it end up with two films was it
one of these things where in the
development process you realize oh my
God this is such a huge story we want
two films or was the studio Whispering a
little bit hey we we'd love to it really
was because we were the story we were
working on we realized later than we
should have that we were trying to jam
two movies into one movie and we
realized that there was the what became
this film was its own full movie it had
a beginning middle and end miles starts
one way and he comes uh you know full
circle and and beca is a different
person who's grown up and has a
completely different attitude by the end
of it Gwen and her father have a
beginning middle and and all the
characters have an arc uh and so it felt
like oh this is a whole movie where
we're trying to jam another movie to the
end of it uh this in and so listening to
the film itself is what made us realize
oh this is the second part of a Trilogy
and so
um and so you know we we decided to make
that move and I think it was for the
best uh because it wouldn't allow us to
like dig in on this on it made the movie
better right yeah how happy was Tom
Rothman and everyone at the studio when
you said I think we need to make two
and say that they embraced the idea and
they do we're super excited about the
fact that we said we were going to need
more time yeah they didn't love that
they loved the idea of it coming out uh
last year more but they've been
incredibly supportive
um and have always uh you know known
that the the brand of these films is
innovation and surprise and um they have
to be like magnificently rendered and
they've always given us what we need to
pull that off oh I give the studio first
of all I want to thank every animator
every single person who worked on this
movie and the first movie for making I
was gonna curse awesome stuff but also
the studio for allowing the thing that I
think a lot of people don't realize is
that the animators have so much
um of themselves in this movie and that
is so unique in Hollywood literally
they're like you know filming themselves
like doing all of the acting and then
composite like five versions of
themselves because there's five
characters in the scene right and then
they use that as reference for you know
to get the really nuanced uh moments of
acting that they're trying to get yeah
they're so much love that everyone puts
into it and they know that they that
they have the freedom to make something
special and and that they and that if it
it's going to enhance the story and and
and and and tell the story more
effectively then it's gonna uh get in so
like giving you know the artist the
power and freedom is is exciting and
liberating and uh and you get so much
better work out of it did you have
character are there characters in movie
three that are not in movie one and two
like you have a lot of new characters
yes
[Music]
um when you guys were writing this did
you end up going down some paths that
were like you thought oh this is
definitely where we're gonna go and then
you realize oh this sucks we cannot do
this we need to you know there's that
scene we tried like 10 versions of it it
never got great it was always good and
so um we we found a better way to do
that right but I still miss the milieu
of that right thing it's like a phantom
limb we'll try to work it into the next
one uh and there's you know there's a
lot the story evolved a lot you know the
character set and the the journey that
Miles goes on you know the specifics the
villain itself you know spot wasn't
where we started but it was something
that
um Avia Rod actually pitched us and
we're like stop the spot that's a
dorkiest dumbest villain he's like no no
he's got a really cool Power he doesn't
realize how powerful he is and then
we came back around going like oh yeah
that people don't realize how powerful
he is and obviously the fact that he has
these portals uh was was relevant like
wouldn't it be interesting to take a
person who is overlooked as dumb and and
feels left out and lonely and wants to
prove themselves the same Arc that miles
is going on but the dark version of it
um and we were like oh we probably
should have listened to him instead of
dismissing him the way everyone
dismisses the spot that's actually it's
funny I was going to ask you how did
spot come about but did you have another
villain that was going to be the villain
of both films or was it one of these
like was it a long struggle to get to
that point where who is going to be a
good enough attack antagonist right to
carry over for two movies well at one
point we did have a third or a second
antagonist that was
um kind of like facilitating and
magnifying spots dilemma and ultimately
like it just was
too far afield from the story things you
care about like you can't get away from
miles or Gwen for very long in this
movie are you kind of like it decays
every second you're away from one of
them like once you start following one
of these characters into scenes that
don't have miles are going in them it
makes it really right but what was
interesting was like well can we pull
off making spot of like a formidable Foe
and it wasn't really until the animation
and the lighting came in for his sort of
transfer full transformation or like oh
yeah this is gonna work this is this is
what we're this is even better than what
we were hoping for one of the things
about the antagonist is you need to make
it a believable that this person can
actually win right then you need to come
up with how the heroes are going to
defeat the antagonist exactly yeah so we
paint ourselves in a corner and then I
have to figure a way out right that's
the best way to write anyway right so my
question is did you figure out when
during the writing process were you sort
of like we're just gonna make him as
badass as we can let's figure out how
we're going to beat him later or did you
come up with that full Arc before it all
you see we actually do know yeah we're
gonna beat him yes and but it was that
it's very unexpected but it was the it
was we painted ourselves in the corner
and it's fun feeling to be like oh
now what do we do because let's make him
as Unstoppable as possible and then be
like oh but now we have to figure out
how to stop him
um and you know we banged our heads
against it and in some of the scenes
that are in the third one are like based
on our conversations of like well how do
you punch a hole do you know what I mean
how do you kick a hole
it yeah it can't be done no
um did this I didn't ask your direct uh
the directors um did this film have a
lot of deleted scenes or was it pretty
much because of animation and the cost
it gets stopped pretty early on no there
are many deleted scenes there's two that
come to mind I'm sure there are more are
they close are they like animated or
like rough animation we never got all
the way into animation on any of them I
don't think we got pretty
far into the camera Department sure yeah
there are moments that are animated like
little little beats and moments that
have been trimmed up but obviously the
finished product is so hard and so Time
and Labor consuming that you know the
finished stuff most almost all of the
finished stuff is in the thing
couple of minutes there are a few like
things that like spot with an ATM like
running around New York City right that
got animated very very early before we
rewrote that scene and they are
somewhere so you're in production the
movie's coming out in a year you realize
the scene doesn't work I need to rewrite
it
um or we need to rewrite it yes yeah
when you actually rewrite it and getting
it animated like what is the shortest
human amount of time from writing
something I will tell you but I'll tell
you because we just went through it it
was we did something we did uh some
rewrites uh on this film about two
months before it was finished and from
we added about three minutes like a
three minutes to a scene right and wrote
it
had it did a storyboard got the actors
to voice it
we were in a real rush because we were
near the end of the production basically
skipped the storyboard right and we even
skipped the camera you're right we were
using we went straight to from yeah we
went straight to we just like basically
paused uh like we took still frames of
previously animated shots right and a
few old boards and through new Dialogue
on top of them and then just send it
straight into animation right and then
it was animated very quickly and lit
very quickly and it all came together
uh like within about eight weeks yeah
two months which was like pretty
impossible it's not sustainable to do
that on a larger scale but it is sort of
if you've already got the the setup and
the lighting and everything figured out
you're like okay we need to do a
different version of the scene because
we it needs to be better and and you can
and everybody's already deep into what
they're doing that's about as fast as
it's humanly possible and updates were
coming in like while we were on the last
color timing right day
like we were ingesting new versions of
lighting uh can I ask what scene this
was or what why did you want to rewrite
this scene um there's several moments
but
um I'd say that one of the things is
um the thing that surprises us all the
time is the audience you think you're
writing a movie that's about conflict
right what the audience really are
hungry for is agreement and watching
people
um achieve a kind of Harmony and so the
the frequently at the end of movies that
same thing happened on the last one we
are adding moments to show characters in
some version of Harmony
and it's the thing that's the most
spectacular thing you can experience in
a movie theater is not people fighting
but people getting along
and you always forget to put it in
put a little uh uh note card on your
computer for movie three you know what
we do and it's still forget but anytime
we get stuck in the scene we just try to
like all right what if everyone in the
scene was just trying really hard to be
nice to each other and even though
they're in it they're having different
points of view they're trying to express
love for one another which were there
any things that you wanted to put in
this movie or in movie three that you
ran into rights issues where you just
couldn't get the rights or because of
the success of the first film everyone
is sort of like oh I want to be in this
we've been pretty lucky with with the
right things we're still there's still
some right things to figure out for
movie three there are countervailing
forces yes if people are excited to be
associated with success but also they
think that success should also shine on
to them so they wind up it winds up
being sort of a push and you you you we
were able to get just about everything
that we were hoping for how did you
decide what the main characters were
going to be in this film and was it
almost other characters was there
another character that came really close
to being one of the protagonists well
what like the main character set came
out of what miles Journey was and and
you know we you know we the story sort
of dictated where he needed to go and
the characters that sort of came out of
like what he needed to learn along the
way you know spider Punk was was a
obvious choice to sort of be the counter
to sort of Miguel's worldview and to be
someone who seems like he might be an
antagonist but ends up being an ally and
we needed a character and he sort of
perfectly fit all the things that we
needed for that but for Milestone almost
didn't make the picture right and then
uh and then
exists because when we wanted miles to
go to another dimension for the very
first time we wanted to feel like
Dorothy coming to Oz as radical as being
in black and white to color we wanted
like what's a place that makes miles
World seem like tame by comparison the
idea of doing like a Mumbai meets
Manhattan super colorful loud Busy World
we're like oh Spiderman India is perfect
for that and then pavitra can represent
sort of
um something that that teaches mile
something as well and and so all of the
characters came out of the story and it
was sort of organic to what we needed
and then anytime we try to add something
artificially you're like oh this is a
cool character but they don't have any
function they just Fade Away into into
the background I am so curious about uh
like Canon points and things that like
make Spider-Man Spider-Man the film
feels more adult than the first movie
because miles is growing up can you sort
of talk about balancing those heavy
moments with everything else right I
mean
and I've never seen it um a great
dramatic film that didn't make me laugh
or like a great comedy that didn't make
me cry you know so I think we never we
don't really think those things are very
inconsistent I think we're just trying
to
um I guess
it's we weren't like oh let's tell a
darker story but I I do think like let's
tell a more
um a richer and more sophisticated story
because you've already done the work of
setting up these characters so it
actually gives you a little bit more
freedom because the audience are with
you
yeah and I think obviously as you said
miles is growing up and maturing in the
film you know needs to reflect you know
the vibe that he has so
um it was sort of it's sort of natural
and you know we're trying to make this
film feel like the most epic and most
important thing in Miles life we the
first movie was the most important thing
that ever happened to miles up to that
point and then now we have to do
something even more try not to tell a
story about the second most important
thing that happens right so it has a
real extra important and there is this
sort of feeling of like the weight of
feeling imprisoned by what you know what
people who are sort of Trapped By
Nostalgia uh and Canon uh think uh is
necessary to tell a story and we
um everything that we do we're always
trying to find a new way to tell to tell
a story that feels like it honors the
thing that we love so much and obviously
this is a character and a universe that
we we deeply love and growing up is
complicated and and your relationship
with your parents gets complicated you
know the older you get yeah and they and
like it's not so authoritarian after a
while you have to meet as equals and
that makes it that's a you know that's a
big adjustment for them yes on that note
I need to stop I'm just going to say
congratulations and I wish I could see
movie three tomorrow